call of duty advanced warfare will have
a new game mode it's called uplink and
it's been sick to oversimplify two teams
two goals one ball yet in advanced
warfare class complexity and the new XO
mods offer plenty of play styles and
bringing that ball home I'm not talking
about more red dot scopes but personal
class specifics that cater to your
preference over styles like tactics
weaponry or mobility that being said I
think I've whipped up the ultimate ball
runner class for uplink and I think I'm
going to pass this recipe for all y'all
to taste test yummy let's break down
uplink first which I played on the
Golden Gate Bridge map defender this
Maps essentially symmetrical where two
floating orb like goals are on opposite
sides of the map further up the beach
follow the maps dividing line down
towards water and you'll not only find
out where the tsunami breaks but where
the ball shaped drone spawns whenever
the drone is scored it'll reset flying
back to this same spot you can score two
ways bring the fall physically to the
goal for two points or if you don't
think you can make it throw that fall
from downtown for a one pointer another
thing to note up linkers is how to
handle your balls excuse me drones use
the right trigger to chuck that drone
down field or toss it to a foe lowering
his weapon and raising yours and then
you got the left trigger for auto passes
to friendlys making for some awesome
place one team one dream so you get the
idea of a blank let's talk about the
perfect class for the ball runner first
match I played I rolled with attack 19
shotgun figured if people are going to
be congested swarming into three
different locations you're bound has
some close encounters hence shotgun
add an advanced rifling mod for
increased range and a foregrip for less
recoil work great especially since many
of the ball showdowns happened inside
the bunker and the shot he was ready to
party looking back on my first custom
loadout it worked all right branded I
was rushed into the first game but after
a couple of matches I was able to step
back and take a stern look at my loadout
and realized I was wasting resources a
drone runner needs to be fast quick
mobile that's all that I even use my
secondary weapon no only the shotgun and
carrying the drone restricts you from
holding a weapon so there's no point in
wasting custom points on a secondary so
pull it put points into your primary and
the primary gunfighter wildcard so you
can add an extra attachment like the
laser sight for increased hipfire what
else can you lose score streaks I mean
your call but this isn't deathmatch any
time wasted on Vulcan beaming or Goliath
his support don't bother with it moving
on to perks perk number one I had an
increased foot speed which worked but
invisible to AV and tracking rounds
pointless once the drone is in your
hands everyone on the map can spot you
tossing and go with the overcharge
perfect which extends your exosuit
battery life allowing you to better your
chances while holding the drone oh
that's right your EXO abilities work
while running the drone making it a must
to rock the tactician wild card giving
you that second XO ability you lose your
XO launcher in the switch which sucks
but again you're not needing while
running the drone so which XO combo
works best I'd say without a doubt
you're picking the XO overclock which
enhances speed so dumb for me I'd say
it's a slight tie between cloak and stem
poking is great for those surprise
moments before grabbing the drone but
when you're running they'll see you the
XO stim offers the stronger guarantee
nuh you can bring that drone home so
i'll say overclock and stem are your
best bet for running and that's that I
use this custom setup and had a pretty
high success rate but hey best part
about the pic 13 and advanced warfare as
you'll find everyone's class will be
different I made the lone wolf
running back but look at the big picture
defensive players could function as
linebackers and safeties while focusing
on score streaks you could even create a
quarterback whose primary goal is just
to rush the ball and chuck it down field
so to each his own but remember one team
one dream
you